the first thing I want to ask you about
his permits what are they
no we the only thing we had permits for
were to shoot on the elevator train and
the way we got that was we went to see
the head of the Transit Authority in New
York and they was not the head he was
the head of public relations and we went
to him my producer and I and we told him
what we wanted to do and we asked
permission to do it and he said you guys
are crazy he said I could never let you
do anything like what you just described
he's a first of all there's never been
an elevated train that was hijacked
there's never been a train crash on the
elevated system in New York and he said
it just would be really difficult and my
producer is Sicilian and he said how
difficult and the guy said $40,000 and a
one-way ticket to Jamaica and I asked
him why a one-way ticket and he said
because if I let you do what you just
told me on that train I will be fired
and I want to live the rest of my life
in Jamaica and so he did happily ever
after I'm told but we obviously didn't
have $40,000 in the budget that was the
budget of the film was a million and a
half dollars and that I went $300,000
over partly because of bribes like that
which which is why in my introduction I
said it just can't be done legally you
can they'll never be able to make this
movie again some of the things that you
and I talked about I had the pleasure of
interviewing mr. freaking with Sonny
Grosso who was the police officer who
was the inspiration for Roy Scheider's
character in the movie and they they
were explaining to me that everything
that you did was essentially with the
blessing of sonny and eddie egan who's
featured in the film eddie egan is the
real inspiration for Popeye Doyle who
plays gene Hackman's boss in the film
and that essentially as I understand it
Egon and Grosso were following you
around town and making sure that you
didn't get arrested for everything you
were doing while you were doing it
we had a egan and grosso who we called
Doyle and Russo because of some very
timid lawyers at 20th Century Fox we had
their rights but we still had to change
their names and change the names of the
bad guys but I think what Sonny told you
is is probably true the case took place
ten years before I made the film and the
case took part over a ten-month period
and the movie runs a hundred minutes and
I think you asked Sonny how accurate was
the film and he said about 95 percent
accurate and what he meant by that was
the film is an impression of what
happened in those ten months an
impression done in a hundred minutes the
only things that did not happen in the
case were the chase scene I felt we
needed that or we would have nothing but
a police surveillance picture and and
police surveillance is like watching
paint dry it is so boring or I must
point out you have about 70 minutes of
that in your movie surveillance it
doesn't seem to ever get boring guys
just well but and so
we knew we needed to have a chase but I
wasn't sure until a couple of weeks
before we started shooting what that
chase was gonna be and one day my
producer and I took a walk from 86th
Street on the east side of New York and
we walked for 55 blocks south and we
said we're not gonna stop we're not
gonna turn back until we can think up a
chase scene and we heard the subway
rumbling beneath our feet we saw the
smoke rising from the streets all this
traffic crowds of people that make up
New York
everywhere and we started to improvise
the chase and that's what we shot you
you and I spoke about the genesis of the
car chase and it's the bits the
signature sequence of the of the movie
obviously the the stuntman who was who
was doing a lot of driving the sequences
is the guy who plays the FBI agent in
the film yeah his name again
bill Hickman bill Hickman and bill
Hickman if you're really obsessive like
I am you'll notice that bill Hickman is
also the driver in Bullitt and he's also
the driver in the 7-ups with Roy
Scheider if you've never seen it's
another great car chase from your
producer
that you had talked to me a little bit
about the conversation that led to some
of the key shots in that sequence well I
didn't storyboard this chase I didn't
write it down it wasn't in any script
but we went to various locations I was a
guy named fat Thomas who gets credit on
the screen at the end as location
manager fat Thomas was a 425 pound
bookmaker
in New York who had been arrested 52
times for bookmaking with one conviction
and he but he knew New York like the
back of his hand
and he took me around and showed me all
these
areas around the area that I got
permission to film the chase
it was the Stillwell Avenue line which
at Bay 50th Street which is just a few
blocks from Coney Island in Brooklyn and
fat Thomas took me to that area and
showed me all around and I chose the
locations most of them under the L
tracks that were there and then other
ones that I had also seen that weren't
in that area that I just sort of threw
in and I would take the crew to all of
these locations about a week before we
started the picture and then we talked
about what could happen and we made some
notes and then we just went out and did
it and there were a lot of accidents
that occurred we had no permits to shoot
the chase none we had no permits from
the city to be on the streets at all but
I had these off-duty cops with me and so
if anything went sour they would just
show a badge and the problems would go
away but we had no permission to do
anything that you see but anyway when we
finished shooting everything that I had
planned I was looking at the rushes and
I thought that it was not very good I
thought it was pretty lame stuff and one
day when we were supposedly finished
bill Hickman and I went to a bar
downtown and had a drink and he said to
me well boss you know he was about 15
years older than me but he called me
boss he said what do you think of the
chase we shot and I said bill I don't
think we've got it I think it's not very
good and you know it's not your fault
it's basically not as exciting as I as I
would have hold and he said all right he
said put the car out there under the El
tracks tomorrow morning at 8 o'clock and
you get in the car with me and I'll show
you some driving so we were gonna shoot
somewhere else that day but I went to
the production manager and I said let's
put the car out on this under the
Stillwell Avenue tracks and we mounted
one camera on the bumper of the car I
operated the camera over bill Hickman
shoulder because both Owen royzman and
Ricky Bravo were married with children
and I was not at the time and we had
another camera mounted in the passenger
seat and that was it and bill Hickman
then drove 26 blocks through city
traffic at 90 miles an hour now we had
there was no warrant there was a kind it
was a warning to pedestrians we had a
police gumball on the top of the car a
siren and so we did have that but we
blew through 26 blocks of traffic
without any clearances no extras and no
permission the only thing that was
staged was the woman with the baby
carriage which was the easiest I would
hope so I think that baby may have grown
up by now no there was no baby you know
that yeah this is the Motion Picture
Academy you know there was no baby but
you thought there was a baby